dando un giro de 180 grados respecto a
lo acordado en 2019 el gobierno de reino
unido prepara una nueva ley para alterar
el protocolo de irlanda del norte
nuestra preferencia continúa siendo una
solución negociada con la unión europea
y en paralelo a la legislación que
presentamos seguimos abiertos a futuras
conversaciones si podemos conseguir el
mismo resultado mediante un acuerdo
negocio sant el protocolo de irlanda del
norte es el principal motivo de
parálisis política en el territorio
norirlandés y una fuente de tensiones
desde que entró en vigor en 2021 pero
que es el protocolo de irlanda del norte
forma parte de los acuerdos del break
sheet el marco legal de separación entre
londres y bruselas con la salida del
reino unido de la unión europea había
que establecer una frontera para los
controles migratorios y aduaneros de
entrada al mercado único europeo
irlanda del norte es la única parte del
reino unido- que limita por tierra con
la unión europea comparte fronteras con
la república de irlanda sin embargo la
reimposición de nuevas barreras entre
las dos irlandas hacía temer el
resurgimiento de la histórica entre
grupos republicanos y unionistas de las
últimas décadas así que se decidió
establecer los controles en el mar de
irlanda entre territorio norirlandés y
el resto del territorio británico estas
disposiciones conforman el protocolo de
irlanda del norte y ha recogido por el
derecho internacional pero la solución
está lejos de ser definitiva el partido
unionista democrático de irlanda del
norte que quiere permanecer unido a
londres argumenta que la frontera en el
mar de irlanda socava la posición de
irlanda del norte en el reino unido- por
lo que rechazan aliarse con el sinn fein
para formar el gobierno regional hasta
que se resuelvan las diferencias sobre
el protocolo el sinn fein que quiere la
reunificación con la república de
irlanda y defiende el protocolo ganó las
elecciones de este mayo pero necesita el
apoyo de partidos unionistas para
liderar el ejecutivo por otro lado
downing street- critica la unión europea
por ceñirse al protocolo de forma
inflexible bruselas asegura que
responderá firmemente si londres
continúa adelante con su cambio que
considera una violación flagrante de un
acuerdo internacional